bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d'écouteurs sans fil vous savez je parle
beaucoup dans des vidéos de smartphones
et je râle souvent contrôle fait que les
marques enlève le port jack parce que
j'ai bon vieux casque sony mounir sont
15 06 que j'adore regarder sur les
oreilles j ai un câble forcément il faut
que je le branche
je suis vraiment réticents à tous les
fabricants qui aurait blé pour jack on
m'a proposé de tester un produit un
casque sans fil de la marque jeannerat
c'est l'élite 65 t et sur coup je me
suis dit je vais pas mourir qu'on je
vais arrêter un petit peu d'être obstiné
et je vais essayer ce casque bluetooth
il est là ce qu'on va faire si vous êtes
ok c'est on va l'ouvrir on va le tester
on va regarder s'il est bien oui ben non
et est-ce qu'au final je serai capable
de changer pour un produit comme
celui-là comme le deviendra élite 65 t
et on va regarder ça
vous savez les habitudes quand on les a
on n'a pas trop envie d'en changer moi
je suis vraiment vraiment vraiment un
amoureux de mon casque donc à ce que
j'ai pas forcément ça m'a tout de suite
mais voyez c'est un vieux casque à
casque de studio là j'adore j'ai le bon
sens très content ça me plaît beaucoup
alors j'ai testé il ya pas très
longtemps si les castes avec réduction
de bruit sa jeunesse il est plusieurs
et je trouve que c'est vraiment le truc
fabuleux moi avec mon casque
le son des cornes un peu extérieur j'en
ai partout je sais ce que c'est qu'un
casque sans fil bluetooth rassurez vous
je suis pas un ignare
j'en ai déjà testé mais pour l'instant
il n'y a rien qui va a fait changer
d'avis mais néanmoins je viens seuil est
celui allant chez un petit message de
nicolas qui me renvoyaient bonjour
aurélien singly que là je suis ravi de
t'adresser ses écouteurs jabra bon test
impatiente connais tes impressions et
d'un mois et coûtera pas si on ouvrait
et de regarder ce qui à l'intérieur et
si franchement ça vaut le coup donc on
va l'ouvrir tout de suite on va les
tester
et puis au final je vous dirais est-ce
qu'il est cool oui ou non donc voilà le
colis que j'ai reçus chez moi alors les
écouteurs sont à l'intérieur on va les
ouvrir et on va regarder au final à quoi
ça ressemble presque y sont cool
est ce qu'ils sont a cause j'ai
l'impression de déballer un cadeau à
noël alors je ne connais pas du tout je
tiens vraiment à vous rassurer je ne
connais pas du tout j'ai pas tricher je
sais pas quoi ça ressemble j'ai imprimé
une doc sur internet avec quelques infos
c'est tout mais nada mas alors fait voir
jabra élite 65 t je dois dire que
effectivement la boîte est plutôt cool
alors déjà la beauté joly effectivement
ça fait pas tout on a ici il a envoyé
quelques temps un peu brillant là sur le
c'est super mignon super mignon alors
qu'est ce qu'il marque supérieur sommes
folles où 145 year one hundred fifty
five years exceptionnels sont alors ça
j'ai vraiment hâte de tester alors ce
qui est très intéressant effectivement
là dedans c'est qu'on a plus de cinq
heures de batterie et 15h avec la petite
boîte qui est déjà chargée donc ça
permet effectivement les recharger
rapidement lorsque vous vous déplacez il
est garanti deux ans contre la poussière
et l'eau bien évidemment sont des
éclaboussures si vous le jeter dans
l'eau je ne pense pas que ça soit
toujours garanti on peut le piloter à la
voix on peut se connecter en wifi
customiser votre musique dont je pense
que tout le système d'égaliseur 1 pour
effectivement avoir le son qu'on veut
c'est en vain sont assez plats si on
veut des bases booster sur de plus des
guillemins il ya pas mal de choses à
faire là dessus et vous avez quatre
microphones qui sont intégrés quatre
microphones qui à mon avis vont venir
capter le son ambiant l'annuler
vous ayez vraiment une immersion
complète au niveau des écouteurs intra
auriculaires voilà pour parler très
techniquement donc je trouve ça plutôt
pas mal pour effectivement un petit peu
ce qu'il va y avoir à l'intérieur la
boîte plutôt sexy
jabra bon bah écoutez on va ouvrir sa
puis on va regarder si ça me coupe alors
attendez intéressant compatible google
play app store et m'aide for iphone ma
question est la suivante comment ça
s'ouvre pour l'ouvrir il faut venir
couper ici pays si bien évidemment sans
se couper le bout des doigts doigt sans
lever comme une chose faite
c'est ça existe comme ça ils aiment
beaucoup ce jonas est très très tonique
ici petite languette je pense qu'un
tiroir
on vient voir alors fait voir le produit
finalement c'est là où on réflective
mans tout le côté marketing et tout
l'intérêt si c'est bien marketé je dois
en prendre plein la gueule
ah ouais voilà voyez ça s'est super bien
marketé welcome to supérieur sand super
bien fait on devine les produits vous
avez lu logo ici c'est super bien fichu
on trouve comme un livre là du point de
vue market c'est très très bien fait
super packaging on arrive paf deuxième
niveau de lecture donc si ces petits
boîtiers où je suppose que je fasse pas
tomber je pense que je vais venir les
rangées là dedans
ok super ici ok pour la recharge les
petits écouteurs le format mini comme ça
va me fait toujours peur j'ai peur de
les perdre de les mettre à mes oreilles
et de les perdre tout de suite c'est
vraiment microscopique j'arrive pas à
croire qu'en mettant en avant ses
oreilles on puisse balader marché sans
risquer de les perdre c'est vraiment un
truc qui fait toujours peur mais ça va
le voir je voulais tester ensuite vous
avez ici une petite encoche voyons voir
qu'est ce qu'on a
olala le petit d'arras a tout foutu
dedans ça j'ai compris j'ai compris
alors bien ici montrent un pin up hockey
get started le petit manuel de prise en
main bien évidemment je suis pas sûr les
lire peut-être plus tard on verra si 20
mois je m'en sors pas la gare entier ça
c'est le câble de recharge pour bien
évidemment le recharger en usb je
suppose que ce sont des petits
adaptateur pour vos oreilles
comment ces fichus donc normalement ça
je retire sa g si mes petits connecteurs
g/km saad dans sa va faire la connexion
et ça va le recharger typiquement genre
truc c'est quand même super bien pensé
je remets dedans paf ça je peux
l'emmener partout avec moi que les
petits écouteurs
moi je trouve que le concept est super
cool donc voilà ces petits écouteurs
auriculaire alors je les ai paramétrer
très très rapidement avec mon iphone
dont j'ai un iphone devient dingue jeu
léger uniquement active et le bluetooth
a déjà reconnu directement alors ici je
vois bien que j'aie le r je le glisse
hop comme ça à l'intérieur on aurait
forcément left le petit bitonio
lâchement que c'est le micro qui va sur
le banc ça directement comme ça à
l'intérieur de mon oreille
voilà je mets lecture sur un service de
streaming de musique en ligne de trucs
gratos alors là j'ai pu se sont un peu
fort donc là je n'entends pas du tout
parlé c'est très très bizarre j'ai la
musique dans les oreilles je me la pose
parce que sinon je n'arrive pas mais
elle ne lâche pas j'ai coupé la musique
jusqu'à une traîtresse d'enfermer et
alors j'ai téléchargé l'application qui
s'appelle jabra stone plus donc là
j'entends un peu extérieur donc là
effectivement je pense que ça capte le
son qui vient de l'extérieur ce qui fait
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui vient me parler
je suis pas enfermée
c'est quand même mon sont rhabillés du
micro c'est très très très très bizarre
comme expérience
bon là je peux régler un équaliseur j'ai
plusieurs fréquences 60 hertz 250r ce 1
kg 4 kg 7 kg 6 bon alors pas rentrer
dans le détail pour effectivement
choisir de mettre plus de basses un peu
plus d'aigus benjamin manceau d'électro
alors je parle est un peu fort en
morceaux d'électro que je connais bien
pour tester un peu le son voir si ça ne
paraît pas mal bien ou pas c'est très
bizarre déjà ses sensations
effectivement là d'être enfermé de
parler comme ça ça dans les oreilles ça
te sens bien je brûle un peu j'ai un peu
trop brive est passé pour le running
c'est une bonne idée ce genre de choses
mais comme ça en tout cas pour écouter
c'est pas mal donc là je veux comparer
je les enlève je m en fous de kalil ce
qui est donc ce électro je mets mon
casque
mon vieux casque justement que j'ai
l'habitude de grancher ans jack mdr
75,06 de sonic cas ce que ce studio qui
est de référence qui marche y parvient
l'ag de la basque chose qui est
vachement défini ça envoie du lourd je
sais pas si vous entendez un peu là là
j'ai vraiment un très grand spectre avec
de la base quelque chose qui est super
bien fichu et voyons voir si je retrouve
un petit peu cette base ici hop
ce qui est bien c'est que gernez
j'appuie sur lecture directement savoir
valls on va pas se mentir j'ai tout de
suite perdu la sensation de basse alors
après effectivement c'est pas la même
chose ça c'est un casque j'ai dû acheter
gars je vous dise pas de bêtises il ya
17 ans c'est vraiment un vieux truc hein
mais qui marche toujours super bien j'ai
vraiment de la basse alors je déteste
les casques petite [ __ ] ce que je trouve
qu' il en va trop de base sont trop
flatteur ça pour le coup c'est un manque
un petit peu mais après une fois de plus
et sur deûle intra auriculaires
fonctionne moins que pat a fait de même
on peut corriger qu'un égaliseur alors
je vais essayer de voir si jamais ça
marche même en montant les basses à fond
dessus c'est pas c'est à ces médiums le
son est assez médiane j'appuie le sujet
qu perd un peu de basses l'âge et de la
basse et ça dépend de la position
comment je le mets dans mon oreille l'on
perd rapidement beaucoup fois que ça
dépend vraiment de la morphologie de
chacun je suis sur l'écouteur de ce côté
là et maintenant je vais brancher mon
casque notre côté le son est vachement
mieux là quand même y'a pas à dire
j'enlève je redis que dans le casque
c'est vachement prime hélium ce qui est
drôle c'est que dès que j'ai piloté je
récupère un peu plus de son un peu plus
de grave mais c'est pas un truc qui qui
complètement dingue je rebranche non y'a
rien à voir
c'est ça qui est bien tout ce système de
casque intra auriculaire
je trouve que c'est pas mal parce
qu'effectivement il ya un côté très très
portatif ya un côté qui prend pas de
place vous le positionner sur vos
oreilles bon à moins de faire des pogos
et de vous jeter partout et d'écouté du
punk sinon ça tire plutôt bien un bon je
pense qu'il faut pas non plus trop
chercher la merde parce qu'après le truc
c'est que vous pouvoir le retrouver
ça n'al'air de race et solides ils ont
déjà fait de trop petits vols ici
malheureusement brouillard tapis au sol
donc ça va ça protège je trouve que le
système qui est super bien c'est
effectivement le système de recharge
comme on peut retrouver sur tous ces
systèmes de écouteurs vous avez comme ça
15 ans d'autonomie et 5 heures en écoute
vous remettez de danse et ça c'est déjà
chargé il ya un format de pocket parce
qu'on va pas se mentir
regardez moi j'ai beau avoir un casque
qui effectivement pratique qui peut se
replier comme ça vous pouvez mettre dans
une pochette mais bon entre ça plus le
câble et ça vous voyagez très clairement
pas la même manière le djia bras élite
65 t c'est bien le son est pas mal après
vous allez il manque effectivement un
peu définition il ya beaucoup de médium
vous pouvez le corriger un peu au niveau
de l'école isr ça change pas non plus la
face du monde ça va flatter un peu plus
mais bon ouais c'est pas c'est pas non
plus un truc de dingue c'est pas à mon
avis de toutes façons un casque est
dédié aux professionnels sur le casque
grand public vole un peu mon point de
vue sur ces écouteurs leggia bras élite
65 t alors effectivement si vous
cherchez une solution portative avoir
des petits écouteurs apporter comme ça
c'est plutôt pas mal fichu
maintenant reste à voir effectivement
quels sont les goûts personnels de mon
point de vue extrêmement personnel je
continuerai
dire qu'il faut que les fabricants
laisse des prises jack on ait la
possibilité soit de voir quelque chose
de vraiment portatifs et d'avoir ce
genre de typologie de produits ou alors
quand on souhaite pouvoir brancher un
casque comme ça il faut qu'on ait le
choix il faut qu'on ait le choix parce
que je trouve ça vraiment dommage alors
appris à naître qui vont me dire oui
mais vous prenez par exemple un iphone
10 par exemple vous pouvez très bien
utiliser l'adaptateur sur le port
lightning et branchez votre port jack
dessus ouais c'est pas hyper pratique
parce que dégoûter le téléphone dans la
poche il ya le truc du bouclier truc qui
dépasse la prise jack c'est lourd
- typiquement bon câble ici une pause
une tonne donc bon bah ça me fait un peu
râler
je ne sais pas si vous connaissiez cette
marque jabra vous marquez tout ça on
commence avec moi ce que vous en pensez
est ce que vous êtes ce que vous
utilisez déjà des casques
intra-auriculaires comme ça sans fil
bluetooth est ce que vous trouvez que
d'un point de vue sonore qualité c'est
bien est ce que vous pensez
effectivement que sa concurrence
réellement les casques filaires
qu'est-ce que filière et casque filaire
mais est-ce que vous pensez que par
rapport à des casques et comme celui là
nasa peut concurrencer n'ont rien
d'autres y en a qui sont d'ailleurs
beaucoup mieux dites moi tout ce que
vous en pensez en commentaire marquer ma
tout ça moi je trouve que c'est quand
même plutôt pas mal plutôt pas mal pour
une bonne solution portative dans les
transports en commun lorsque vous
balader en ville ça vous évite d'avoir
un gros casque vous avez rangé dans un
sac à dos après 6 et ça s'est rapidement
embêtant ça c'est vraiment côté très
pratique on était dans une poche et on
en parle plus mark et moi tous vos avis
en commentaires dites moi si vous
pourriez vous laisser tenter sur cette
typologie de produits et notamment sur
le jabra élite 65 t bien évidemment
comme d'habitude vous invite à laisser
des jolies pouces vous invite à vous
abonner on reste connectés parce que des
choses comme ça des choses high tech qui
vous rendront service dans la vie de
tous les jours on va en parler toujours
plus merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo comme d'habitude vous embrasse il
est très gros bisous soyez sages pour
les soins que vous et à bientôt
ciao
m